all right so let us begin today's
meeting
it's a great pleasure to be here thank
you very much to the organizers for
giving me this opportunity my name is
Dennis vedasif
I'm originally from Moscow State
University and for the last like seven
years I've been doing some research in
Geometry topology of those geometric
things and for the last two years I
began to
apply the geometric ideas and geometric
instructions to machine learning and
data analysis so during some joint pro
project program of the university and
the Huawei Corporation
we try to use geometric methods to make
machine learning algorithms better to
better I don't know
find anomalies in images to
face out to improve face recognition and
stuff like that and today I'd like to
share some of these ideas some of the
basic instructions and the applications
so how geometry can actually help in
data analysis and enhance our methods
and algorithms
so the overview of my talk is not very
long so first I'll be speaking about
what is a manifold so this very basic
construction very basic object of
differential geometry then we'll look
into how manifolds appear in data
analysis why is that interesting why
they are important and then we try to
apply them
and study them in two ways first we will
discuss the dimension estimation of
those manifolds and then we'll talk
about Matrix on those manifolds and we
understand why Matrix on the manifolds
May improve
this is the machine learning results and
sometimes they're absolutely necessary
so if you don't look at the manifold we
just can't get accurate results
let's begin
most basic thing what is a manifold
I'll try not to
you know use some very algoristic
approach with a lot of definitions and a
lot of special terms so just
if I try to show it if I try to explain
it then in a very basic sense a manifold
is just a reasonable formulation and
generalization of course of the idea of
a surface so everyone knows what surface
is the most common surface we know is
just a plane or if we look for higher
Dimensions it could be
multi-dimensional euclidean space so
like R3 or like R5 or whatever
uh manifold somehow expands this notion
generally generalizes it so here I have
this pretty nice in my opinion a picture
of a Taurus another very simple yet much
more interesting object much more
interesting manifold and looking at it
we understand we see that clearly the
source is not a plane
something different but
how is that connected what is it what is
exactly the difference so for example
can we
take the Taurus and form it somehow to
get well maybe not a plane but a sphere
actually that's a very basic question of
differential geometry and more
specifically of topology so if I have
two surfaces two objects like that can I
deforming one obtain another
the answer to this particular question
is negative no
no deformation of the Taurus is sphere
but why
I'm not sure that we'll be able to
answer this question exactly today but
at least we'll understand the the
objects we're working with so how do we
construct a manifold how to as one talk
at some conference was titled how to
fold a manifold so what has a basic
constructing blocks of it so let's take
a disk a disk now usually this can
euclidean space RN for this particular
example I'm taking a two-dimensional
disk on a two-dimensional plane here it
is
uh
actually this and this dimension of the
equation space RN
from which we take the disk
later will become the dimension of this
manifold of this whole manifold but for
now we work with a very simple object
maybe the simplest possible without with
an open disk
and then we start to deform it in this
again example I took the disk and
started to deform it in a
three-dimensional space R3 actually I
can take a
some high dimensional space in for
example deformity are four or five or
whatever and later we'll see that in
reality this ambient space where we do
to form the disk doesn't matter it may
not exist at all
but for now for our example let's take
this particular case where we form our
two-dimensional these kind of
three-dimensional space
uh
one thing to note is that this initial
disk doesn't have to be circular so here
I drew a circular disk but actually I
don't need it any disk at all
is suitable so what I mean on saying any
disk it means that
any object
two-dimensional which can be
continuously deformed
when I say continuously it means that
I'm not allowed to glue some points
together or tier my disk so
for example I can describe it like that
any object
on the plane which by continuous
deformation because in any dimensional
euclidean space both elbow yes yes so so
if n equal to
uh well it's a question of terminology
usually in my area in my differential
geometry and dimensional balls are also
called and dimensional disks it's just
synonyms and in that sense yes the
soccer disk is a two-dimensional ball
we take anything which could be
continuously deformed into like this
circular ball disk however we want to
call it
and then we
take our first deformed disk take the
second one and glue them together with
some overlapping so here I have this
picture it's not
exactly what what I mean since here you
can see that we have two uh disks the
blue one and the green one but they are
glued by their boundaries they are not
intersecting
actually imagine that
those blue and green disks actually have
some overlapping so they're just like
lying one another and because of this
coloring we can see it and so we
continue this process we are taking more
and more these of the same dimensions
that's important so in our case we'll
take all the D's of Dimension two and
continue to construct this Patchwork
like surface
what we end up with is a manifold
So speaking more precisely what is a
manifold it's some set of points in for
example R3 or RN such that the
neighborhood of every point
small enough neighborhood looks like a
deformed disk from RN so in our example
any point if if we take uh let me think
yeah if we take any point here and take
a small neighborhood of it it will look
like just a deformed disk from R2
that's the idea of a manifold so we
begin with a simple thing a part of the
euclidean space for example a plane and
then we make something more more complex
more interesting out of these basic
pieces
one more uh step of obstruction which is
actually quite important in many areas
maybe not so much in data analysis but
still
we consider this manifold not to believe
in some ambient space around so like
here we had our Taurus glued from these
pieces
to be like to be lying in the R3
but we can forget about this R3
so we can look at this manifold
like it is existing all by itself there
is no ambient space where it lies or how
the geometrists say
the space the manifold is embedded into
it's just all the world we live in so we
have only this manifold and nothing else
at first this notion this idea of the
surface being
all the points we can work with could be
a bit I don't know destructing and
unclear but there is a very real life
example which somehow for me illustrates
this idea very very well here it is so
that's a picture I took it from
Wikipedia it's created to unisa and it's
a illustration of the current
Incarnation I'd say of the Bing Bang
Theory of how our universe appeared and
developed and so for me when I first
heard of it
it was very very strange how can I
imagine
the Big Bang so the point in time before
which
our universe didn't exist at all so how
our universe cannot exist
somehow for me it's strange I don't know
maybe for you it's more I don't know
understandable but for my imagination it
was hard to to help him but then I
looked at this picture and I think I
understood it bad look
this thing here
is our space Style
so that is there that's for the sake of
simplistic four-dimensional manifold
where we live so three dimensions of
space and one dimension of time it's all
one surface one manifold complex big
convoluted I don't know but one manifold
and that is the example of the manifold
all by itself there is no ambient space
where it lies in it's all literally all
our universe so there is no ambient
space to to lie in
all the points we have every moment in
time every point in space lies on this
manifold and then we can see that the
Big Bang is just one point on this
manifold just here so it's not that
before this point
there was no universe or whatever
it's just that when we try to look at
our universe from this linear linear
time point of view when we're moving
like from here to here then yes
in that sense
there was nothing before just because
it's the local minimum of this surface
so if you can see this is the local
medium in this direction
but if we look at this manifold
in general look at it and we see that
well it's just just one point on the
manifold and yes that is a topological
manifold in the sense that it doesn't
lie in some ambient space and some
higher dimensional Universe I don't know
but maybe it does maybe it doesn't
according to current series it does but
from our geometric
point of view that's that's a mindful we
live in and that is it's well kind of
beginning but actually it's just one
so
now we have some better understanding of
what a manifold is so again some set of
points such that a neighborhood of every
Point local neighborhood looks just like
the form disk from
RN of sound fixed n so this n is
constant for all the points of the
manifold
and let us move to the second
or or maybe applied part of this idea
how to find many folds in data analysis
why are they interested and first of all
we understand perfectly their geometric
representation of data of data points
naturally and frequently appears in both
statistics in data analysis and machine
learning and whatever so here I have
three examples which I like
the the difficulties difference so first
one is just a linear regression where we
to put every data point on this
two-dimensional plan and then find the
line which in the best way approximate
them then here we have the principal
component analysis diagram where again
we have a lot of data points scattered
somehow in the two-dimensional plane and
then we try to get some
in reality geometric characteristics of
this set so even though principal
component analysis is sometimes
formulated in statistical terms so we
take the covariance Matrix we take some
eigen vectors sort them and take the
longest ones but actually we find this
vectors which are spanning in a way our
cloud of points and then we forget about
the shortest ones and project
our cloud of point of points on the load
lower dimensional Subspace
making our job is there because a few
dimensions then
it is as easy it is to to work with the
cloud and the last but not least example
here it is it's a diagram of convolution
of neighbor a neural network or at least
the first part the convolutional part of
it when we begin with an image so this
robot here
and then we try to we start to um
so contracted with some kernels
many times in many layers
and in the end we have the output and
this output is just a long long vector
so it is a point and some abysmally high
dimension of each space
so again we transitioned from the image
in this case to some point in some
higher dimensional space euclidean space
and as you probably know the dimensions
of such spaces are tremendous so for
example in the um
concrete examples I worked with we had
like thousand seven hundred
the dimensionality of this space and
that's a lot
that's really a lot and it's quite
difficult to work with such spaces
like
just taking them
raw over there
so okay we have geometric representation
but where are the manifolds of course
euclidean space you couldn't play in
here here and euclidean space here all
of them are manifolds of course but they
are not very interesting manifolds and
there is no real reason to introduce
this whole manifold Siri to just
describe Glidden spaces but actually
what is important for us is so-called
manifold hypothesis that's what it is
called in the literature for example
here is one of the more or
on the point papers on this matter so
testing the manifold tab what is this
and for this hypothesis states that
actually if I take cloud of data points
in some high dimensional feature space
and I take those points not arbitrarily
so I don't just take some probability
distribution and shoot those points into
the space but I obtain those points from
some real live data so for example if I
take this uh this image and then using
the neural network transform it into the
long Vector in the feature space in that
case is those points they don't occur in
the euclidean space
randomly all over the place but they
actually lie along some
quite low low dimensional manifold or
manifolds inside that high dimensional
space of course when I say here they lie
along I don't mean that they exactly lie
on the surface so that there is some
tools two-dimensional Tools in a
1700 dimensional feature space and all
the points are situated exactly on the
stores now that's not true and that
couldn't be true well maybe it could but
in that case our world would be much
different from what it is
uh but they lie in a close vicinity so
in a small neighborhood of this uh low
dimensional manifold and for the
purposes of our research we can actually
consider them lying on this manifold
and that means that when we look at the
cloud of points of it data Cloud we
actually can and should try to find this
manifold structure so the manifold where
those points actually live and apply the
knowledge of this manifold to better
understand the structure of this of this
data and there are two maybe Main
major directions in the study so first
part we need to understand what is this
Dimension so how large actually is this
um is this manifold
in some sense what is the volume of the
uh of the space of the of the play is
better to say where those points
actually so for example if I take I
don't know this linear regression and
imagine then these all these points lie
very very close to this red line so
here's a reasonably scattered but
imagine that they're very very close
then
the dimension
actually is that that is one of the
examples of this manifold hypothesis so
then the dimension of the place where
the spawns live would be very close to
one because this line is one dimensional
manifold it's a curve and
in all the two-dimensional space the
points would only uh
span something one dimensional or very
close to it so in general if we have
this 1700
dimensional space and we have points
there what is the actual Dimension where
what is the what is the place where
we're living in for example I can right
now give some numbers
so when we were working with some open
data sets of uh images of people of the
faces photos
we had this
1700 dimensional space but the actual
manifold where those points live was
like about 30. so the
dimensional reduction is tremendous from
more than one and a half thousand we
came to
certain dimensional manifold it's much
easier to work with to understand to
test fashion and the second part uh the
second main direction is construct
construct metric so
is this way to measure distances and
uh differences in this sense between
points on this manifold as opposed to
metrics in the ambient space I'll talk
about that a bit later in more detail
but for now let's talk about one
particular method of dimensional
estimation uh before I delve into this
minkowski Dimension notion and here
we'll have some formulas hopefully not
much yes sure this is
during the density function is a medical
ah
it is a Surface yes oh yes for example
that is true that is true yeah sure sure
absolutely
we know from calculations
yes that's that's right
manifold since the
corresponding Matrix
that's right so one absolutely so one of
the most uh well started maybe and most
common
um kinds of manifolds are just actually
Graphics of some functions so for
example if I have like a function of n
arguments and then for example it's
mapping from this RN into r
then the graphic of it would be a
surface and manifold in r n plus one
and in yes that is a example of
manifolds and of course they are the
most common metric is just induced from
the euclidean space but there are other
kinds of manifolds for example the ones
which can't be uh the whole manifold can
be
constructed as a graphic of some
function of any function such manifolds
exist and in that case well there we
have to start examine with different
instruments for example we can take them
locally so watch by patch
and again as I said not every manifold
is considered to be lying in some
ambient space and in that case I can't
induce a metric I don't have the a magic
consent in space
uh all right so before delving into the
minkowski dimension notion I'd like to
say that one of the again most common
ways to estimate
in reality exactly the dimension of this
manifold from many hypothesis is this
principal component analysis model
method which I mentioned and yes how it
works so for example if this cloud is
very very seen again then I have two
principal vectors one is very short and
I disregard it and I estimate the
dimension of the manifold where these
points leave to be a rounded one so it's
very very seen area
of course it's not exactly one it's
really two-dimensional but I can
approximate it like that
the problem with principal component
analysis is that it usually in most
cases it's it overestimates the
dimension so for example imagine that my
uh my manifold my data set is very
very curved it rounds on itself
and then for example it can live on some
two-dimensional surface I'll show you an
example in a second but if we apply as a
principal component analysis
other
principal vectors would be quite large
and this method would estimate the
dimension as a dimension of the whole
ambient euclidean space for example
three so
sometimes we need some more subtle
instruments to
to look at it and so
here is one of such instruments uh for
more detail you can refer to our paper
well it's actually a preprinting archive
which were
[Music]
Road during this joint project with
Huawei
so there we used two actual methods of
dimensional estimation one was purely
geometric that's the minkowski dimension
and the second one was more
probabilistic uh I won't be talking
about date today because our time is
limited but we'll concentrate on
zaminkowski Dimension so originally
zaminkowski Dimension was devised and it
appeared when people tried to
invent what is the dimension of some
fractal set so you know fractals there's
cells which somehow repeat itself so if
I zoom in on this on the set I'll see
the very same set again
and those are not manifolds they're
pretty
badly constructed I don't know how to
put it better and for example they can
have fractional dimensions and the usual
notion of Dimension is just kind of
applied to it and so
Dimension appeared so let us describe it
and Define it
so first of all let M be some set
in RM not necessarily enfold some set of
points and let us cover I'm sorry for
the type let us cover this RM by
distinct D dimensional cubes with side
another type I'm sorry side R and note
this set by VR so we um
usually this is D and M are the same so
again for the sake of Simplicity let us
cover the RM with M dimensional cubes
and naturally those tubes
are divided into two groups some of them
intersect our set M and some don't
so let us consider the number and
denoted by n of R it's the number of
Cubes such that their intersection
without set m is not empty
we can understand and imagine then when
we make this
the size of the cubes smaller this set
of Cubes intersecting M would better and
better approximate the M itself
and the minkowski dimension is defined
as follows let's let us take this number
of Cubes intersecting M and take it
let's say in logarithmic scale so log of
this and here I don't have the basis of
the logarithm considered to be whatever
it's unfixed number for example it could
be a natural logarithm hello
then we divide divided by the logarithm
of with the same base of 1 over r
and we look at what happens to this
fraction when we make our cubes smaller
and smaller and smaller so when R goes
to zero
if this limit exists of course it's not
always the case but if it exists then
this
number is called the minkowski dimension
of the set M important thing is that if
m is actually a manifold a real manifold
as I described then this bench Dimension
exactly coincides with the usual notion
of Dimension so with the dimension of
these discs the manifold was glued from
okay but how to calculate it how to get
it from our data here is the
illustration
so here
if we have the manifold and dimensional
manifold action
then when R goes to zero when it's very
small then the number of those
intersection cubes
is almost like the volume and
dimensional volume of this manifold for
example what is it
and dimensional volume for example for a
curve it would be its length
for a two-dimensional surface it would
be its surface it's a square for
three-dimensional manifold it would be
its volume and so on and so forth
uh and we divided by R to the nth power
where n is exactly the dimension of this
molecule from this we can see that
logarithm of n
for small R's is just logarithm of V and
V is some unknown to us but it doesn't
matter it's just a constant we have some
manifold of unknown Dimension and it has
some particular volume
so it's a constant minus n logarithm of
r i just obtained it by applying
logarithm to both sides of this
asymptotic equation equality so we can
see that logarithm
of n
is a linear function
whose argument is logarithm of r and the
uh coefficient is exactly the dimension
so if I calculate this n
first arm R then for small R small R and
so on and so forth then the graphic
would be something like that
we would have this linear function this
one
here we have minus logarithm of R okay
here we have logarithm of n which we can
actually compute
and the angular coefficient Alpha uh
it's tangent tangent would be exactly
the dimension we are looking at
so if we have a manifold that's what
kind of what we can do we can break our
space into cubes
then for many values of R we calculate
the
um the n
look at the graphic calculate
it's the derivative and it's a dimension
of course when we are talking about not
a real manifold but a cloud of points we
have some queries for example
imagine that they are the side size of
the cube it's very very small
it's smaller than the minimal distance
between our points well somehow
normalized doesn't matter then
every Cube would either contain exactly
one point of our set or zero points
just because if the cube is very small
smaller than this number let's say it's
smaller than this number then no two
points of this Cloud could appear in the
same Cube and that may it means that
when R is smaller than that so when
logarithm minus logarithms is bigger it
is we would have just constant our
function would be constant it ceases to
to change
so
in that case we have to carefully find
this piece of the curve which is
actually meaningful linear part
right here so before this critical value
of logarithm logarithm of R and
calculate the derivatives there because
of that we can't calculate the dimension
exactly but we can get some estimations
and exactly in this way in our paper
which I mentioned we obtained the um
estimation of the dimension of this
point of cloud of points obtained from
the
from the photos of people
so this is one of the
possible and interesting and
computationally quite
quite nice it's not very computationally
hard ways to estimate the dimension of
this menu
what is the medical in the first figure
here oh I'm sorry set of points but we
have this domain we have this curve it's
dashed
sit here this curve and the points lie
in a closed vicinity of this of this
curve so the manifold is a curve it's
one dimensional manifold
in this picture we had exactly this
curve and we got a very nice straight
line and the derivative is just just as
a dimension of one
in this case we have just a cloud of
points which lie closely include in a
small neighborhood of this curve because
of that again we calculate the same
logarithm of n plot it as a function of
minus logarithm of r
so R is just here it is the PSI side of
the square so our cubes here are squares
and look at the look at the graphic and
again take the lining apart
calculate the derivative and we have the
dimension
that is true that is true that could
affect it but if we take for example if
you have a lot of points here for
example along this part of the curve and
here we have virtually no points then
this method would what would it
calculate it would calculate the
dimension of this part of the curve
right but manifold it's like uh the
dimension of its every part neighborhood
of every point is the same so if I can
just calculate dimension right here
then I know the dimension of all the
manifold because it's constant so in
this in that sense the mykosky dimension
is pretty robust so it's it works pretty
well with different sparsity and
condensation of data
of course some extreme cases could screw
the results
I think that there is no absolutely
accurate way to estimate the dimension
without any misgivings but it's pretty
nice
this one
this one or
well
sorry so we have this graphic is on the
x axis we have minus logarithm of the
side of the square or the side of the
cube in general and here we plot the
logarithm of the number of Cubes
intersecting our set
which different this
[Music]
or any manifold which no the minimal uh
they're actually the manifold which
let me explain so again we have this
asymptotic equality so the number of
points the number of Cubes intersect in
the manifold is
um looks like the volume of the this
exactly this manifold divided by R to
the dimension of this manifold and so
when we calculate it for the cloud of
points it would give us the best
estimate uh which manifold those points
could lie on or very close to
such that this asymptotic quality holds
that's it so of course again of course
it could overestimate and ever
underestimate the dimension sometimes
for example if imagine that my uh again
manifold is something like that
it's a serpent which very densely covers
this this Square then most likely
unfortunately when we have the random
points around this serpent then
unfortunately the minkowski dimension
most likely still would see the whole
square and its answer would be two so it
overestimates
in some cases
for example if our data is not uniform
then for example I could have a
two-dimensional manifold but for some
reason my points appear on some line on
this two-dimensional manifold because
for example I don't have sufficient data
then the minkowski dimension would
estimated the dimension as one but
actually it's two I just can't see it
together
right now I don't think that I have on
my fingertips as a exact formulation of
the theorem so which conditions should
be satisfied for the dimension to be
exactly what is it is um
like proposed we have some experimental
data on artificial and real data sets
and we see that yes the estimation is
good
all right so let me talk a little bit
now about the distance between data
points about the dissimilarity so one of
the most things that I have not much
time left so I one of the most common
ways to for example
work with face recognition so after the
neural network I have these points in
higher dimensional space and I try to
thicken the tail test point for example
using the simplest model the K nearest
neighbors model I just try to understand
whether it's one person or another by
looking at the closest point to this one
but there are some interesting things
which can occur for example look here uh
those three points green red and blue
they all lie in a plane which is
parallel to this one
and so looking at them we can clearly
see that well the red point is close to
to the green uh to the green one then
the blue one so this this distance is
greater than this one
let's go just looking at it using for
example euclidean distance or actually
any standard metric and a standard
distance in the euclidean space like
blinkowski distance the Manhattan
distance euclidean distance whatever we
see that yeah those two points are
closer to each other and so using the
for example one nearest neighbor model
we would classify as a red
point
in the same class as a green one and the
red the the blue one in some different
class but what happens when we look at
actually the manifold where those points
lead here it is
and we understand that in reality we
should have been measuring the distance
not in the ambient space because ambient
space knows pretty much nothing about
the spawns in reality
the manifold knows more and we have to
calculate the distance along the moon as
a manifold and then between the green
and the red points we see this long long
way long long curve
and between the red and blue the curve
would be shorter
and we understand that actually our
original idea was wrong
when we calculated the distance in the
Collision space we got some results but
when we look at the data closer and when
we take into account
as a manifold it lives on we see that no
the distances were wrong
and actually this uh so red and blue
Owens for example should belong to one
class and the green to another
uh here I have this uh maybe cryptic
paragraph about what the remaining
metric is so I'm not sure that I have
enough time to delve deeper into this
idea just saying very shortly that
usually metric is some mapping between
from pairs of points to real numbers
which satisfy some axioms so the
distance is always non-negative if
points coincide the distance is zero and
we have this triangle inequality
in differential geometry we work with
something a bit different it's called
the Romanian metric and in reality it's
just the scalaro dot product into the
tangent space to the manifold so if I
take point I can consider the tangent
space
in the usual sense the tangent space to
the to the surface then I have vectors
in this space and the remaining metric
just tells me how to multiply them
surprisingly this very small as it seems
information is enough to uh calculate
lengths of Curves and shows the distance
between points so how do I calculate the
distance between two points I just take
all the curves connecting those points
calculate their length and take the
shortest one so
hands from the remaining metric I get
the distance between points and well so
as we can see the real problem and the
real advantage of the differential
geometry in this setting would be to
measure distances between data points
not using the ambient distance
whatever it is but using the inner
metric using the structure of this
manifold via the data points
so
why is knowing the dimension is
important
first of all is the case is pretty
simple
like when the BSA is is good and
supplyable then we can just
straightforwardly reduce the
dimensionality of our data set by
projecting it to some lower Dimension
linear Subspace that would principal
component with the sa I don't know PCA
of course component and necessary
um
what does the PCA do it just finds this
good linear Subspace and projects the
points onto onto it as I said in this
case it's a very commonly used
data set manifold called Swiss roll
the PC most likely would overestimate
the dimension because it's very
non-linear it's very
um current
then the second advantage of knowing the
dimension is that
well I know that there is some manifold
but I know don't know what it is and how
to find it and if I have the dimension
then at least I know at what number of
parameters of actual parameters of
substantial parameters to look for
then the third thing is that I said that
remaining metric leaves in the tangent
space and it appears that constructing
tension space from this uh just data
points we have this Finance data data
Cloud would be
all by itself very good for constructing
better distances better metrics and
these
construction of attention space
needs for example let me let me put like
that if I want if I have a data point
and I want to construct the tangent
space to my manifold at that point
then I have that I need exactly as the
dimension of the manifold are the points
in the neighborhood
it turns out that those points well
first of all I only need for example 30
not 1700 but just so it's much easier to
obtain and then those points could
attend artificially for example if we're
talking about image recognition we can
use the augmentation technique where we
slightly distort
our image for example rotate it or shift
it and those artificially obtained data
points would still lie on our manifold
in a closed vicinity of the point we
begin with and then we can construct
tangent space and
the distance would be much much better
and the results of financial recognition
would be again much better we had such
experiments and final
bullet in this in this slide is
algorithms for geodesic shooting so
geodesic is exactly this shortest curve
and if I take a point
I can take some direction and knowing
the dimension I can construct the
geodesic which lies in my manifold and
goes well wherever it goes
for example if I in this way construct
judgesic which connects one of my points
to another one then here I have the nice
inner distance between those points
along the middle
between any two points we consider a
distance s points in manifold
distance in ukrainia exactly yes yes but
why it is better uh here is the example
so here we have for uh so why it is
white is more accurate so this picture
shows why it's different right so we
have the euclidean distance between red
and green smaller than between green and
blue but uh distance along the manifold
is vice versa but why it's more accurate
well actually because
uh
this manifold so for example I take a
neural network and process my photos for
example and then I get points and some
euclidean space they lie on the manifold
and structure of this manifold uh
reflects their
um
the relationship I'd say between those
points
like why we take I don't know why we
using linear regression why we take
point on this straight line as a
prediction for our process well because
we see and suppose that
those points lie near near this line so
these these lines is one dimensional
describes how they
how I don't know their nature right and
in general case this manifold which
exists by the meaningful hypothesis
these manifold describes the nature of
the data boards and that is why when we
walk Acro along this manifold
this uh is bad estimation for example uh
we can look at the
curves along this manifold like
continuous deformation of my photo so
for example just just random example I
have I don't know a golf player who is
hitting a ball
initial position is here and the final
position when the ball is I don't know
far away is right here
this curve would give me a continuous
set of photos a continuous set of
pictures where he is moving
it's continuously deforming
and if I take this route then it would
contain some I don't know a craft and
horrific
creations with many hands many balls and
I don't know what else so those points
are not meaningful in the sense of this
data set and those points are that's why
looking at the manifold is more accurate
all right so I think yeah my last two
slides
the question is can we actually
construct this manifold the answer is
partially yes so this manifold
hypothesis unfortunately hasn't yet been
approved analytically so I don't have
again and no one has the ethereum that
yes under certain conditions the points
line close the percentage over the
manifold what experiments data from Real
World Time After Time affirm that yes
this manifold exists though it may be
quite bad so for example it may be not
connected it may consist of several or
maybe maybe a lot of distinct pieces
and in other ways it also could be
pretty bad but still it's a manifold or
something very close uh then how to
construct it we have some dimensionality
reduction techniques which not only
estimates the dimension but also how to
create the construct the manifold a good
example is non-linear right a principle
component analysis which finds node this
linear Subspace but something more
curved so some surfaces are manifold and
also there are different attempts to
approximate the manifold in the
literature it can be found and if anyone
is interested I could just give the
references and give the papers so people
try to intercept quadrics so quadratic
manifolds consider something called
cylindrical bundles and wouldn't go into
that right now and using other geometric
methods
looking at the data Cloud to
approximate the manifold and
the last slide of this talk
what should be done what are the first
directions where do we go from here so
first of all we should concentrate on
making better metrics constructions so
look at data Cloud try to construct a
manifold try to create some accurate
remaining metric for it then we can also
look for new methods of dimensional
estimation and costly Dimension is good
and nice and probabilistic math is that
good but again as we discussed they
don't work always and first of all it
would be very good very profitable to
that's right formulate some serums which
state exact conditions when this method
works or this message works or none of
the message works and we can devise new
methods
uh the Third
point is well what I was talking about
just right now how to make better
approximations of this manifold
more accurate more and is a easier
computable
and finally as I said it would be great
to have rigorous formulation and
analytical proof of the manifold here
what is this to exactly understand what
is the geometrical structure of the data
points taken from their real life
so I think that that's all for my short
talk today so if there are any questions
or comments or discussions please I'd be
very happy to answer whatever I can
yeah sure actually from your last two
slides
most of these questions are not solved
but there's a lot of work in this area
that is true so yes my last slides
shouldn't be taken as their signs that
this is this field is completely you
know Terror Incognito there are plenty
of works on all those bullets so people
try to prove meaningful hypothesis and
understand exactly what it means
there are works on approximation of the
manifolds different methods of
dimensional estimation some methods not
that many but still some message of
construction metric but still there is a
lot of you know area of improvement in
this in this field that's why I put them
here yeah I was trying to imagine the
diffusion Maps reactive diffusion maps
all right
in some way yes sometimes you managed to
compare your results with what they have
not really it's something in our plans
but not yet
first picture you are using two items
that will create those white you can use
one item
uh
one item what do you mean you use two
pieces this is a green this is the blue
and green ones yes you can use one
no because if I take the whole surface
of the tools as one as one piece it
wouldn't be a deformed disk
again on these yes okay okay so yeah
that's right so
here I use two to this to create half of
the tools of course I could uh no no so
uh for the toes I
the minimum number of this would be four
so I would have least one
this one
and the same on that
on the other side yeah
amongst two metals what is better
oh well
that's a good question and I think that
the most accurate answer is that if we
use supervised learning we have our
training data set and we can and we have
the as label the data and then we can
just adding to it look at both metrics
and decide which beta reflects the what
is happening with the points but of
course if a somehow constructed this
manifold then we can just look which of
the Matrix is actually the metric on the
manifold and which is not and then take
the one on the manifold if both of the
metrics are on the manifold then well
only on exponential
because of course on the same manifold
we can define a lot of remaining Matrix
and they are not uh Better or Worse per
se so they're more suitable or not and
that depends on the data
uh I know of some uh Works in these
areas so in Moscow our colleagues and
sculco are used some of the techniques
but I don't know quite about the results
so yes that's something I debating
including in this talk and decided
against it but yeah
yeah
that's correct that's correct
thank you very much it's been a pleasure
[Applause]